[Music]
yours count they don't get out can you
believe it's been 15 years soon now I
can't it goes by in a nanosecond you
know how you really know that time is is
when you see the kids in the family that
used to hold when they were born and you
are now at a gathering and you're
holding their children my husband and I
follow look the Lakota Sioux tradition
the Native American traditions we do the
sweat lodges vision quests my husband's
a Sun dancer and these wonderful elders
taught us so much and this was Bearheart
Williams who was one of our elders was
coming into town Sunday night to do run
a sweat lodge for us and we go in there
to pray and the material that was even
being shown to me to audition was
garbage and I told bare heart that I
want to think I'm gonna retire and he
said he's from Oklahoma he said Shelley
when you get into the sweat lodge what I
want you to do is to be very specific
exactly what it is you wanted you so got
into the sweat lodge and I said I'd like
to be in a really good comedy
well-written that says something fifth
banana and if at all possible in front
of a live audience that was Sunday night
Tuesday and my agent called me and said
they just sent faxed me some material
for the show that's already on the air
this is the last episode of the first
season would you read it so he faxed it
to me and I looked at it and I said to
my husband Walter I said honey help me
learn this I connected immediately to
Rosario went out here CBS Radford I was
sitting in the waiting room at scene
there crocheting and Max and David
and Jim Burroughs came in and saw me
sitting and crocheting in the fun who's
this weirdo and went into the room they
were all sitting on the opposite end of
the room and I grabbed a chair and I
dragged it over to where they were
sitting and I said is this gonna take
long I have to go home and cook a
chicken got back into the car you had
car phones then and my agent called me I
said how did it go and he said you start
tomorrow and I found out later they had
read quite a few actresses but there was
something about Rosario she reminded me
a lot of my mother straightforward solid
honest and hysterically funny did the
first show it was so brilliantly written
I think Adam Barr was the one who wrote
that episode although they all
contributed and it was the last show of
the first season and every the crew the
crew is the one that kept coming over to
me and saying you're gonna be so on the
night that we filmed it in front of the
live audience and after it was over I
can't remember now who was the head of
NBC I can't from scotts a so that they
they kept changing and he announced that
the show was picked up they didn't say
anything about me but the show was
picked up and I think it was a few weeks
later they called me and they said
you're coming back it was lightning in a
bottle and we all had each other's back
it was I knew I would be back I knew
that I would be used as seasoning I
wouldn't have the a and B story I would
work between it and it was perfect and
the people we got to work oh my god
everybody everybody in Hollywood wanted
to be on that show every start
because it said something because it
said something at a time when god bless
ellen degeneres she opened it up he
cracked it open and took all the heat
but just recently Vice President Biden
and President Obama both have said in
different ways that certain films and TV
shows help to further social justice and
Obama said films like guess who's coming
to dinner and TV shows like willing
Grace said something we had bomb threats
la police department guarding every
possible entrance and exits B we'd get
these weirdos who would come on to a
plate or just I put their hands on our
head and say you're gonna rot in hell
for doing a show like this you know but
my husband and I this isn't the early
80s when people didn't even know what
aids was we worked with a lot of people
and with the medicine men many people
who had AIDS we worked with their
families
we've come a long way but there's still
a long way to go and thank God we okay
Shawn would tell me about the letters
that he would get when we were doing
Will and Grace and Megan would tell me
we would all share the letters we would
get from teenagers that would say thank
you for saving my life or now I can
really talk I can sit down and talk with
my parents or so many to use what you've
been taught to use as a creative person
and align yourself with all these other
creative people and make people laugh
and at the same time make them want to
move forward come out of the dark ages
and you can do so much more with humor
that's why they'll show these shows they
can show them in perpetuity and they
would still be meaningful and people
watch them again and again and again
there's a rhythm to it and they feel
like they're part of the movement and
until the movement you won't even have
to think about it
[Music]